was going to be an attorney many years
ago
and then i decided to kind of make a
really sharp left turn and become an
actress it's a good thing she did
because the young and the restless star
michelle morgan just received a daytime
emmy nomination for outstanding lead
actress in a drama series michelle
joined et canada to look back on the
accident that made her rethink her
career i broke my neck in a car accident
um and when i was 19 i kind of made a
deal with myself and i deal with god
that i'm like if i get out of here and i
can walk again i'm gonna try i don't
know what that means but i'm going to
try so
after that everything all the pieces of
the puzzle just started falling into
place michelle first portrayed hillary
in ynr before the character suffered a
fatal car crash in 2018. she later
returned to play her twin sister amanda
you may never
be able to look into hillary's eyes
you can look into mine
michelle also explained how much the
emmy would mean to her and why the win
would be a historic awards moment i
think it would just kind of
confirm to me that i made the right
decision that you know that i can
actually achieve a level of success and
greatness i'm like i would be the first
woman of color the first visible
minority that actually won um in the
lead category so i think on a bigger
scale i would be honored to just kind of
receive that um on behalf of everyone
else who
in the past felt scared to kind of go
into this category
you